[Music]
and then of course there's my nanny's
Brooke he'll choose everything for me
this season's bachelor villain Corinne
has been vocal about her nanny on the
show one viewer is so concerned though
he created this go fund me page for
Raquel the page describes Corinne as an
entitled brat and says quote let's all
help Raquel get a better job to give
back on her own two feet
let's help free Raquel she thinks sure
that my bed is made every morning makes
my cucumber and my like vegetable slices
for lunch the goal amount is one hundred
thousand dollars and Corinne is firing
back the 24 year old posted this to
Instagram quote this is not a joke
anymore Raquel is not a slave and my
family and I treat her like part of the
family et spoke with former bachelor
favorites Ali Fedotowsky who had a vist
to say about Karen's nanny
this woman Raquel her nanny obviously is
her family's housekeeper and she
probably was Corinne's nanny maybe she's
been with the family for a very long
time she probably was Karnes nanny if
she was growing up
but now she's that her nanny she just
Corrine still lives with her parents and
the housekeeper's still there and still
doing things for her so there's a big
distinction there but someone who has
sorry I mean I hate to be mean but like
someone as immature as Corrine thinks
it's funny to tell people she isn't in
[Music]
you